[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o tour já
quando me convidaram para ser oradora
terex é minha reação imediata foi sim
então era isso é que esta malta não
sabia que para mim falar para três
pessoas já é uma multidão mas depois eu
pensei
a pequena e por que não tem nada a ver
com o meu tamanho
aproveito esta oportunidade para poder
definitivamente o medo de falar em
público e para poder partilhar o meu
sonho e esse que vai fazer convosco e o
meu sonho é devolver ênfase às crianças
o que eu quero dizer com isto eu quero
que as crianças todas as crianças do
mundo tenham a oportunidade de desfrutar
e viver a sua infância plenamento como
uma etapa da visa e não uma etapa de
preparação para a vida eu não sei vocês
mas eu também não era preparado para ser
idosa
sou só mais voltar a disputar esta fase
da vida pois é isso que eu quero para as
crianças e que elas tenham a
oportunidade de fazer aqui o que elas
fazem melhor que aprender a aprender
descobrindo o mundo é explorando e
criando a certa altura este sonho sofre
uma pequena alteração o grande já é um
caminhão ambicioso eu penso que se torna
um pouco mais ambicioso ainda é nessa
transformação que eu quero falar
e tudo começa num dia que eu achava que
era igual a todos os outros estavam de
bastante quente as crianças estavam a
brincar no exterior e amazon renatinha
na cabeça uma tiara de brilhantes que
transformavam em uma linda princesa
neste espaço no entanto não tinha
nós os adultos claro que tínhamos criado
uma regra ea regra é para brincar no
exterior teve que usar um chapéu boné
para termos a certeza que as crianças
não têm qualquer esquecimento
organizamos nos destinos com chapéus e
os bonés que colocamos estrategicamente
passeio do projeto ruim e agora começa o
problema mas ainda quero brincar no
jardim mas não quero deixar de ser
princesa
amanhã então a esquecem um detalhe
importante esta criança só tem três anos
em maio
lembrem-se presentes em maio um
importante detalhe eu dei mandato já que
nessa regra sabe que para brincar com a
fora vai ter que colocar um chapéu
estou convencida que estou a ser
altamente democrática
a regra é razoável concordam comigo não
é eu estou levar duas opções
no entanto esta criança somos e olha
sentava em silêncio e eu insistindo mas
a reinar fora chapéu dentro que era quem
convença madalena é deixar de ser
princesa e vai me olhando em silêncio e
em silêncio que esta criança
levanta-te e caminha serenamente para
assentar na sombra de uma árvore pois é
nesta altura a minha vontade foi a
terceira que além do pescocinho não foi
só voltava a pé e sobram o segundo é que
no olhar desta criança não havia
qualquer expulsão do desafio ou
provocação bem pelo contrário esta
criança com apenas três anos em maio
tenham um olhar inocente mas mesmo ao
mesmo tempo sabe olhar de alguém que
lhes vez margarida é que também posso
brincar e não preciso usar chapéu
na época ela tinha razão e essa criança
demonstra não só um pensamento lateral
ao também desenvolvido a capacidade de
escolher entre a hipótese de ver para
além da solução a ou ver uma solução
fora da caixa
como é que a base algo ainda mais
incrível
foi foi ver uma solução empática uma
solução em que eu fique satisfeita
porque a criança não vai apanhar uma
solução ea ong no a brincar no jardim é
ser princesa a partir desta altura eu
pergunto mas então qual é o meu papel
qual é o meu papel com as crianças qual
é o meu papel é ensinar o vício não é
sempre vai estar frio que aprendi esta
doeu
então a resposta a esta pergunta veio um
dia com uma imagem que estava por muito
março a cabeça de falto pré-sal violento
e foi essa imagem a imagem de uma dupla
espiral
imaginem crianças que vai inocente
altamente conectada cheia de entusiasmo
criativas e vem concretizar todos os
seus sonhos e dons dons no plano da
matéria
a primeira parte da espiral vem
concretizações nos dons em 3
mas então qual é o meu papel eu descobri
que o meu papel é é apenas e só este lar
pela sua segurança física emocional e ao
mesmo tempo por seu proporcionar os
meios para que consiga concretizar todos
os seus sonhos e dons ea segunda parte
da espiral
essa foi outra descoberta minha neste
momento eu percebi que o papel das
crianças na minha vida era fazer e
conduzirem é que eu fizesse um caminho
do ingresso
andré esta nossa se conhecem autor do
livro nunca fui à escola diz que um
adulto é uma criança que proveu
entusiasmo pois através das crianças eu
acho que não porque eu eu acho que será
um caminho neste caminho do regresso eu
recupero meu entusiasmo e faço quando
estou por dentro com as crianças
uma presença consciente de corpo mente e
espírito
para terem uma idéia
e eu consegui explicar onde vai o que
significa pôr parece algo estranho vou
contar a história do vasco
o vasco é uma criança tinha seis meses
quando começamos a ir ao jardim a
passear e eu eu como gosto contato
físico e também porque não tenho jeito
nenhum com carrinhos de bebê
optei por carregar na mochila neste dia
já com oito meses
no regresso a casa encontramos uma
senhora a varrer as folhas do jardim e o
vasco como todas as crianças é curiosa
esticar o seu pescocinho eu já sei que
alguma coisa me chamou a atenção e para
oc vasco vamos parar aqui e o vasco
observou a senhora a varrer o chão as
folhas e ele ficou observar e eu com
isso
entretanto já expliquei a senhora que
esta é uma atividade que já chama a
atenção do vasco outras vezes e pra ela
não achar um pouco estranho estarmos ali
os dois parados olhar para ela e ele
ficamos e ficamos nisto mais de dez
minutos mas dez minutos o vasco tem oito
meses apenas oito meses o que é mais
incrível é que a vida continua a
acontecer
as pessoas continuam a passar e o vasco
está 100% nesta actividade é verão
estamos no jardim do juízo mas o que é
mais incrível é que não foi só o vasco
ficou nesta atividade nesta observação
atenta e eu também
eu nunca na minha vida tinha gasto o meu
tempo a ver varrer pelo menos não com
atenção na atividade em si não é 100% é
tentos
eu completamente envolvida na cnaa que o
movimento da vassoura no chão e descubro
que há algo hipnótico irlanda santini
isto 100% atento oito meses
temos ou não um expert em maio funai
pois esta descoberta fez com que eu
quisesse mais pessoas possam passar a
fazê lo ao fazê lo comigo
e descobrir que a solução encontrada em
uma coisa que chama a pedagogia 3000 e
para isso tornei-me facilitadora do
projeto 3.100 chegava da bolívia ilha do
sol facilitadora de visitas por dia 3
mil
o que é isso a educação do terceiro
milênio não é um bicho de sete cabeças
de educação do terceiro milênio e é um
convite para criar com consciência uma
educação integral uma educação que é
humanitária ecológica prática vem
invertidas não é divertida não é
sustentável e que visa um mundo de paz
portanto nós trabalhamos muito a cultura
do paço suja é só para usar assim os
fatos muito rápido em relação a isto
surgiu em 2001 portanto já tem quase 19
antes no mundo no equador pelas mãos
deste assim acreditava em uma mp mal se
falam um pouco dela também e espalha
rapidamente na américa latina e depois
também por todo mundo e nas porque na
sobretudo a curiosidade desta senhora
que é uma senhora foi a campo e não para
já fez várias figuras mundiais da entre
o pólo da francesa determinada altura
valor para que as crianças estão ficar
algo diferente
os princípios uau é eu penso que se eu
perguntar muitos de nós vão achar que
têm filhos netos sobrinhos alunos cansar
um pouco diferente ou algo estranhos ou
pelo menos um pouco de frente como nós
éramos quando tínhamos a idéia de luz
depois de fazer algumas investigações
com uma equipa multidisciplinar durante
alguns anos esta senhora chegar à
conclusão que de fato as crianças de
hoje estão diferentes e para isso cria
uma uma proposta mas para dar resposta a
estas necessidades não só das crianças
atenção também dos pais e dos
professores que têm que cuidar
com elas mas não tem ferramentas para
tal e cria esta proposta às escolas 7
beta hoje e chama-se escola das sete
pétalas porque cada pétala
correspondendo a uma área do
desenvolvimento do ser humano
o desenvolvimento físico onde kaká por
exemplo o judo que salvou o marion do
mario
todas as atividades físicas dessas do
esporte
tá bem nesta pétala o desenvolvimento
cognitivo é articulado e divertido
porque articulado por nós queremos saber
para que serve este reconhecimento que
estou a aprender o que eu posso fazer
como eu e como tinha dito antes
divertidos não é divertido não é
sustentável
não queremos gênios que as crianças a
ação não cremos gênios intelecto homens
envolvidos mas não que não tenha uma
inteligência emocional também
desenvolvida que não sabem lidar com as
suas emoções ou que não sabe relacionar
se com os outros a pétala rosa aperta o
desenvolvimento emocional e da
multiculturalidade a pedra branca da
estética da beleza da arte cabem aqui
todas as pessoas artísticas
o contacto com a natureza como se ensina
o respeito pelo nosso planeta
se as crianças aprendem das plantas e
das áreas das artes num livro
não queremos que as crianças aprendam na
prática estejam um máximo de tempo
possível na natureza e que estava em
coisas como a permacultura as hortas
orgânicas as energias alternativas e
renováveis ofício pôr a mão na massa e
aqui temos sua por exemplo a combinar ea
lavagem todos os ofícios também possam
imaginar a e que nos permitem também
descobrir qual é a nossa vocação para
que eu tenho jeito que eu gosto de fazer
finalmente até apertar lá a violeta do
atual conhecimento quanto a mim é
o mais importante é se nós conhecemos
conhecemos os nossos interesses nos
conhecemos conhecemos nossos dons
conhecemos as nossas emoções
tudo o resto flui naturalmente e agora a
eu quero dizer uso algo que é muito
importante as escolas sete pétalas ou é
apenas uma proposta que pode ser
aplicada num contexto educativo mas
também por exemplo no achismo macaléia
numa sala de aula não é nada que se
possa copiar ou aplicar taxativamente
precisão existem dois espaços que sigam
esta proposta sejam iguais também vos
quero dizer que não interessa se chama
pedagogia 3000 se chama sete pétalas foi
o que se chama mário não sendo aquela
linda mas eu já fiquei fã do mario a não
importa o que chamamos o que importa é
que aceitamos o desafio e é com desafio
exatamente o que eu quero terminar o
desafio é prestes a mudar o teu olhar
entrevistamos a ver as crianças de outra
forma a ver as crianças como seres que
são completos que são perfeitos estão
cheios de potencial atreve te ver o
mundo através do olhar da criança e com
certeza mais bonito que o nosso a minha
vida tornou-se muito mais divertida
atreve a às lembra o entusiasmo pela
está um pouco esquecido dessa nova
perspectiva
o desafio é criarmos uma nova educação e
direcional a educação para uma nova
sociedade
inevitavelmente para um mundo novo
aceitar o desafio
[Aplausos]